[Music]
we have a big monologue on Oprah tonight
I hope you want to hear my take on that
that's coming up in just a minute but
first we have to start with tonight's
breaking news both John Solomon and
Sarah Carter this hour are reporting
that congressional committees are now
trying to determine if FBI agent Peter
struck and as FBI lawyer girlfriend Lisa
page literally leaked information about
the Russian investigation to the press
now here's why
Solomon reporting that text messages
between struck and Paige appear to show
that in fact they had advanced knowledge
about a Wall Street Journal article and
it was about to be published now take a
look at this text exchanged between
Paige and struck that was obtained by
the hill page tell struck article is out
but hidden behind paywalls so can't read
it and struck response Wall Street
Journal boy that was fast should I find
it and tell the team there are also
other text messages about the media like
this one struck saying yep the whole
tone in the anti bu meaning the bureau
just the tiny bit from us Paige replies
makes me feel way less bad about
throwing him under the bus to the
forthcoming CF article Wow now according
to the hill Congress is now trying to
figure out what the CF article means and
who's struck in Page we're trying to
throw under the bus now there's a
message here in all this Lisa pate says
well we got a list of kids with their
parents names how many of this reporter
from the New York Times could be there
in DC the hills reporting that struck in
Page exchange the text messages about
tracking down information about a New
York Times reporter that they were
referencing in that text why would they
be looking into a New York Times
reporter page then writes Wow found what
I think might be their addresses to and
struck says he's totally slubby don't
you remember and struck in Page also
take horrible shots at the New York Post
colleagues Chris Wallace and former
colleague megyn kelly
mocking the Trump Hotel in Washington DC
and saying they hope it fails horribly
they never stay there and both reports
are now saying that because of the
existence of various text messages that
reference the news media congressional
investigators are now
working rightly to determine if there
was any improper leaking to the press
about the Russia investigation how else
would you interpret those words John
Solomon Sarah Court are they going to be
here with all the explosive details
that's coming up and also tonight
members of the media liberals in
Hollywood they're absolutely giddy
tonight over what Oprah Winfrey speech
at the Golden Globes which I would say
was very good many are saying it sounded
and she sounded presidential and it was
a campaign style delivery and according
to new reporting Oprah's now considering
running in 2020 here's the part of what
Oprah said at the Golden Globes let's
take a look so I want all the girls
watching here now to know that a new day
is on the horizon now to the media the
left in this country OPA Oprah
apparently is their chosen one she's the
new Messiah that they will blindly
worship and follow like the sheep that
they are and here's why
the media and the left in this country
well they now seem to think that Oprah's
the one person that hopefully can help
them fulfill what is their ultimate goal
to destroy Donald Trump and defeat
President Trump just look at how the
media how transparent they are fawning
over Oprah's speech does this remind you
a little bit of the same people that
never vetted Obama you know seven and oh
wait we don't know a lot about Oprah's
politics at all we know she's a very
likable person on TV and a pretty
inspiring life story but watch this
she's known as the queen of talk and
last night the world was listening the
all-star crowd captivated by her
poignant message of female empowerment a
speech so inspiring many now calling for
Winfrey to add yet another title in
front of her name president
[Applause]
bringing the audience to its feet
setting a new tone for Hollywood and men
and women around the globe after that
speech she had quite a few people in
that room saying they sure did like the
sound of president Winfrey if she were
to get in the next day she'd probably be
leading the fight for the Democratic
nomination she'd be leading the
Democratic ticket nor I was back in the
one-on-one rooms while the speech was
going on I will tell you this everyone
was mesmerised that speech last night
was not only empowering and
inspirational but I thought it also
echoed a lot Hillary Clinton's
concession speech it was like five
minutes of desperately needed therapy
speech that gave people hope and it
reminded people what is so great about
this country and the strides that this
country is made and how we still have so
much to be hopeful for it that doesn't
show their bias oh yeah it does now I
have to the speech NBC they even tweeted
an endorsement for Oprah look at this
nothing but respect for our future
president
now after NBC called out for their
massive display of bias they deleted the
tweet and quickly tried to shift blame
to someone else by putting the statement
on Twitter that says quote yesterday a
tweet about the Golden Globes and Oprah
Winfrey was sent by a third party not
them an agency for NBC entertainment in
real-time during the broadcast it is a
reference to a joke made during the
monologue and not meant to be a
political statement well that's what
they have MSNBC for they're the
operative arm and basically an extension
of the press office of course of the
anti-trump media we've since removed the
tweet really does anyone believe that I
personally don't a third party agency
what they trying to get some poor kid
fired over this
anyway NBC got caught red-handed and
they're now trying to spin this and hope
that will all go away let's be honest
here when you're talking about NBC
they're not fooling anyone about where
their politics and their political
allegiances lie look at conspiracy
theory 24/7 MSNBC hate Trump hate Trump
a Trump that's our programming for today
an NBC like the rest of the media they
despise they load they hate the
president and it's not a secret so let's
just all stop pretending because the
game's over
by the way NBC wasn't the only destroy
trump outlet too he prays on Oprah
take a look at these headlines you got
the New York Times President Oprah after
golden globes some have a 20/20 vision
USA Today
Oprah 20/20 Winfrey's Golden Globe
speech has fans dreaming a presidential
run deadline
Oprah kicks off 2020 White House bid and
other surprising moments from the Golden
Globe Awards The Guardian could Oprah
Winfrey run for president and wind and
then there's Hollywood after last
night's speech all of these private jet
liberals were all showing off their
newfound political affection for Oprah
this is their new Savior take a look
there is a movement afoot back here
Oprah 2020 I'm not kidding
[Music]
that was the immediate reaction online
just please rock me
I think she's our next president I'm
crossing my fingers didn't any of them
ever say a nice word about Trump ever
the economy's to them better than it has
in eight years
where does Oprah stand on the issues and
it doesn't end there here's what Meryl
Streep is saying about Oprah quote she
launched a rocket tonight I want her to
run for president I don't think she's
had any intention of declaring but now
she doesn't have a choice
poor Oprah are you hearing that your
life is now committed and others like
Obama's former speechwriter his name is
Jon Favreau he got in the action of
tweeting Oh Oprah Winfrey's as brilliant
and inspiring as any public figure today
she doesn't directly speak to celebrity
America she speaks to America don't
underestimate her at CNN political
analyst April Ryan tweeted this if Oprah
ran for president in 2020 she is every
person she has been poor now rich he's
also a self-made billionaire she has a
grasp of the issues as she used to cover
local politics she can articulate any
issue and she has mass appeal beyond
race and gender look I know you people
in Hollywood and all of you in the
liberal media I know you're all
intoxicated and addicted to Trump hate
but maybe you might want to just put a
little bit of pressure on the brakes
here with your Oprah obsession you know
are you really ready to go that deep
into what Oprah's speech which I thought
was brilliant in many ways I have no
problem with Oprah Winfrey what she did
last night in many ways was great I'm
glad to see she stood up for women
especially in Hollywood I support that
as I think everyone should and I also
think Oprah has a tremendous capacity
for human empathy you've ever watched
her show she has an incredible strong
personal story overcoming sadness and
tragedy in a horrible upbringing I
applaud her for what she's done in her
life and politically all I know is that
she supported Barack Obama other than
that I don't know that much about her in
terms of running for president and as to
the media and the snowflake Hollywood
left take a deep breath control your
giddiness I know you hate Trump let's
not jump on the Oprah 2020 train just
yet the economy has never been better in
eight years and I know you don't like
that this
it actually stands up to North Korea and
Iran and he's not trying to bribe
murdering dictators you're gonna get a
have to get used to peace through
strength because it actually worked so
buckle up it's gonna be a rough three
years from here now that's the problem
with the lie I will never understand why
they're looking for a messiah a savior
somebody that's going to come in and
save the country we don't need another
liberal chosen to fix our problems with
more government Reagan once said
government is not the solution it's the
problem we need more individual freedom
in this country we need more liberty in
this country we don't need more liberal
policies out of Washington look at what
those liberal ideas did to the economy
and foreign policy in the last eight
years can you even look you all loved
Obama his track record was atrocious and
so to all of you starstruck people out
there tonight looking for your next
chosen one you may want to relax and
stop trying to buy your ticket on The
Oprah 2020 train and here's the other
point tonight the hypocrisy from the
left liberals the golden glow that's
stunning but sadly it's not surprising
it's very predictable everyone just like
in the liberal meeting everyone -
basically a person praising Oprah and by
the way to the degree Hollywood for
their movement about me - etc it's great
what Oprah did by standing up for
victims of sexual misconduct and abuse I
think it's awesome but we can't forget
that misconduct is and has been rampant
in Hollywood for decades I don't trust
anyone that they really in their deep
heart of hearts except the people that
were victims you know actually believe
all they're saying at this point why
because there's a lot of hypocrites out
there on this specific issue for example
remember how Hollywood embrace director
Roman Polanski this is a guy that was
accused of raping multiple times a 13
year old girl this was in 1977 after of
course he gave her champagne and
quaaludes and at the time Polanski was
43 he was eventually charged with six
felony counts but he fled to Europe
before being sentenced now you would
think that after that Hollywood bee
would be completely in the business of
disowning and renouncing Polanski that
never happened
here's what it did instead back in 2003
Polanski won an Oscar for Best Director
and the celebrity-filled audience
erupted in applause like I'd never heard
before
even though Polanski can't come back to
America because he was avoiding
authorities overseas listen to the level
of cheering when his name is called out
by Harrison Ford watch this
Roman Polanski
[Applause]
really standing ovations raucous
applause for a child rapist of a 13 year
old he gave drugs and alcohol to and it
gets worse
Hollywood support for Polanski didn't
end in 2003 when he get the Oscar when
he got the Oscar in 2009 after Polanski
was arrested in Switzerland in
connection to the 1977 case that he ran
away from we had over a hundred
celebrities many Hollywood signing a
petition demanding his release so like I
said it's all great Hollywood pat
yourself on the back
fifty thousand award ceremonies a year I
can't stand it or watch a second of it
but it really it took decades and
countless people that suffered before
you finally are able to do it and do it
right